what's the deal with airplane
peanuts comedy Mothership in Austin
Texas hey this is red coming you live
from the comedy Mothership here in
Austin Texas since opening their doors
only 8 months ago the comedy Mothership
has quickly become the premier standup
venue on planet Earth Joe Rogan's new
club is home to some of the biggest
comics in the game and the mothership
door staff is stacked with up and
cominging talent as well with thousands
of Comedy fans traveling to Austin Texas
every week to get a glimpse of the
mothership Joe Rogan's Club has already
made some serious contributions in
changing the comedy landscape forever
and with the insane amount of notoriety
surrounding this club there's always
been lots of debate around if anyone
would ever get to film a special at the
mothership and if so who would be the
comedian to do it first in today's video
we're honored to be joined by the man
who accomplished that feat the one and
only Brian Simpson Brian Simpson thank
you so much for joining the show today
my first question for you filming your
special at the mothership that's a big
deal so what was the process like
getting permission or just pitching the
idea of filming a special there in the
first place oh that was actually the
easiest part honestly because like from
you know from the moment I met uh I met
Rogan I mean well at least from the
moment he saw me being funny you know he
was like oh I support you however I can
whatever you need don't need Tri and you
know and I never asked him for nothing
but then I was like Hey I want to fil my
special here he was like yeah I know
that you uh filmed a special for Netflix
so were there any differences recording
your special at the mothership or
recording your standup half hour on
Netflix as far as constraints or
freedoms with the entire process well
yeah yeah because the you know the half
hour is not that's produced those were
produced by Netflix God damn it Millie
okay all right you know there's there's
a lot less input in terms of you know
the look and the feel and you know you
don't have a lot of input in terms of of
of you know the way to set is set up and
the lighting and none of that stuff was
it fun to film your special in your home
Club club that you're used to being on
that stage or I know some guys will go
to a different uh place on the road and
pick a city that maybe they haven't
played before so I mean you know I don't
know I mean this is my first I special
so I don't have any other thing to
compare it to but yeah there's some
there's I would I would imagine there's
something to that just filming you know
somewhere where you're comfortable even
though you know the room didn't look
anything like it normally looks they
they change it so differently like
you'll see when it comes out you'll be
like this doesn't even look like the
same place have you decided where and
when you plan to release it no no no
those the big dogs get to get to pick
their date I got to like slip get in
where I fit in so it's a lot of people
on the horizon and so I have to wait
till some certain other people decide
when theirs is going to be released so
the Austin comedy scene as a whole has
been exploding obviously over the past
few years as being a part of that a key
component in that where do you see the
Austin comedy scene 20 years from now
honestly I think I think people are
going to look back to now as the
beginning of something I think just
comedy in general is changing right now
because you know because the culture is
Shifting so rapidly and that's so much
about what what comedy is relevant and I
think you gonna see here in the next
four or five years like all that
gonna get put to the to the
Wayside and the real GNA it's going
to shine through I think that's why it's
it's really popping right now too and I
think people are just getting more and
more tired of the too I I
completely agree filming like like we
said before filming at the mothership
for your special that's a really cool
thing are there any other plans for
comedians to be filming specials at the
mothership or was this just your idea
that you thought of first and then
executed because it seems like something
people would want to replicate there's a
handful of other people who I know are
filming theirs but I don't know if I can
say okay so but yeah it's definitely
gonna and I think if when mine comes out
if it's if it's well received I think
it's going to turn into a it's gonna
open the flood gates cuz it is it's a
great place to film did you do anything
different like the stage design you said
is a little different but the people
that were in the room was that just a
regular August 27th at the comedy
Mothership where it was just tourists
and just regular people in there or were
you promoting to to your audience come
see my special get filmed here it's hard
to tell man cuz the cuz the you know the
weekends at the mothership just sell out
every time so it's hard to say whether
they were Mothership fans or Brian
Simpson fans but I'll take them I think
most Mothership fans are probably Brian
Simpson fans too once once they go in
there at a certain point you're just
like I saw roast battle a few times cuz
it's it was I just want to get into the
mothership so let me get tickets to
whatever they have available and
sometimes that was Rose battle sometimes
that was someone and friends and
whatever and people are just excited to
go into this building to see Jokes which
I feel like is very rare oh yeah yeah
it's awesome I mean if if you're a
comedy fan you got you have to come to
the Mothership at least once yeah you
know I think that's what a lot of people
are doing but also if you a if you're a
comedian you got to come to the
Mothership at least once it's the only
Club where all the money goes into the
club every other Comedy Club has to
survive and Mothership don't have to do
that we all see those pictures of the uh
the red neon don't be a sign and
that cool snake table and all that stuff
how how dope is actually being in that
green room and hanging out with people
oh man it's amazing honestly man I laugh
more in that green room than I do
anywhere else I guess that is that is a
a little a little uh a little taste that
most people don't get to to experience
but no it's it's amazing it's it's one
of the nice nicest green rooms I've been
in for sure all right well last question
for you here Brian I I really appreciate
your time today um is it true that you
have a special pair of Crocs that you
only wear on stage and were those
featured at all in the special well you
know was funny that used to be true no
let me let me let me rephrase that that
that is true now I used to wear my Crocs
to the club and then change into shoes
before I went on stage and change back
in the Crocs and then I think it was um
I think it was Andrew Schultz that was
like why don't you just wear the Crocs
on stage that's I mean that's what you
want to do yeah you know because he
asked me why like why do you do that I'm
like oh because my the Sho the shoes
hurt my feet I got you know and he's
like why don't you just wear the Crocs
stand I'm like you know that's not a bad
idea who gives a well Brian thank
you so much again for your time today if
you have any upcoming dates or social
medias that you want to shout out and uh
maybe a ballpark time if you know when
uh when your special's coming out too if
not we're obviously going to keep an eye
on it and make sure people know obv say
early next year and um yeah and just
follow my podcast BS with BR Simpson
well thank you again Brian guest spot
from last week The Joe Rogan Experience
had un regi wats and Brian Redban two
bears one cave was Tom and Matt rif kill
Tony this week had on Joe list and sugar
Shan Ali Matt and Shane secret podcast
was Matt and Tony henchcliffe are you
garbage had on Rob iser Rob was also on
taste buds battling Shake Shack vers
Burger King the honeydude talked with
Jason Muse Adam Ray was a guest on
Whiskey Ginger flagrant did not have a
guest your mom's house had on Joe list
and first date featured Mark Norman
we'll just move on to our dessert
question time flies when you're having
fun what is don't look oh sorry what are
you doing you can't look over there
that's oh I I just saw the clock I
didn't see anything else and I saw a red
flag but that we already knew that was a
thing I love my little cheat screen over
there oh yeah they love me they help me
that's what I call
PornHub a cheat
screen this past weekend with theovon
spoke with Anthony jessick the Tim Dyan
show was a solo episode Paul ver was on
tiger belly the Blox podcast had Andre
on the program Joe bartnik was on hey
babe we might be drunk head on Russell
Howard Chrissy chaos welcomed Andrew
Dice Clay Rick Glassman had Berke Cher
take his shoes off being I with Jordan
welcome Jared freed David Bor and
Langston Kerman visited stav's World
kill Tony golden ticket winner Rick Diaz
was on joke World stos hus got on sto's
wild ride and the Adam friedin show sat
down with Chad Hanks as far as any new
standup specials are either out right
now or coming out soon Joe perah slow
and steady is out right now on his
YouTube channel un fortunately deep
down it's okay don't sweat it we reset
it okay all
good
okay don't feel B you just ruined my
entire
life Pete Holmes has a new hour of
standup comedy ready to premiere on
Netflix titled I am not for everybody we
also have Heather McMahon's son I never
had coming to Netflix October 17th
Whitney Cummings new special mouthy
premieres November 11th on only fans TV
and Dan Soder will be recording his new
hour of standup at Helium in Portland on
November 15th and 16th also for any fans
to kill Tony out there I would
definitely recommend watching the video
that we posted yesterday detailing the
upcoming matchup between Hans Kim and
Rick Diaz the man who won a golden
ticket on Kil Tony 628 and has been
trying to challenge Hans Kim for his
spot on the show ever since so are you
still trying to protect H
Kim oh my God you literally are leaving
the United States of America next week
yes sir and you have one more Monday
left in town one more Monday to take a
man's
job we even got a chance to interview
Rick Diaz about the entire situation you
can find that video on the end screen
right after this thank you for watching
and please subscribe just click it it's
free at joke
world that's did it joke
world and the world is w rld
D that's a great uh YouTube channel joke
World check it out